- So Sandra's character plays,
she writes guilty pleasure novels.
So what's your guilty pleasure
or do you believe in it?
- That's the thing,
I don't really believe
in guilty pleasures.
I feel like at one time
I would refer to my love
of like reality TV and The
Bachelor as a guilty pleasure,
but I now just have to admit that I'm
unironically enjoying it.
- You just like it.
Unironically.
- And it's yeah.
So I guess that, like
I didn't watch the most
recent series of The Bachelor
'cause I've been doing press and stuff,
but I hear it was mental, but
or the end anyway.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, so,
Love Is Blind also took
up a lot of time during filming.
- Wait, does Erin get you into these
or are you the one that's like so?
- Erin got me into it initially,
but now I have to own the
fact that I'm also like,
hey you wanna put on Love Is Blind.
- I love it, I love it.